we begin with this two teenage boys will
now be tried as adults after being
charged with the murder of a
photographer in Ohio
Victoria Schaeffer died instantly on
Labor Day when she was hit by a 74 pound
log at a park in Hocking County now this
log fell from the edge of a cliff
prosecutors say that two 16 year-old
Jaden churches and Jordan Buckley are to
blame for that
Jericka Duncan is here with the latest
on the case Jericka good morning to you
the whitening why are they facing these
charges as adults well it really comes
down to intention the prosecutors
claimed that churches and Buckley pushed
the log that killed Victoria Schaefer
now a grand jury will ultimately decide
whether or not to indict the sixteen
year olds not only on murder charges but
felonious assault and involuntary
manslaughter charges as well but the
attorneys for the teens argue those
charges are far too harsh on September
2nd Victoria Shafer was out taking
senior pictures for a group of high
school students at Hocking Hills State
Park in Ohio that's when the
photographer and mother of four was
struck by a six foot long 74 pound load
that fell from above without warning it
killed her instantly students and other
witnesses immediately called 911 I can
understand you what happened
is her chattering and falling at the
time authorities began investigating
whether the tree section was dislodged
on purpose last month they determined to
16 year old boys did in fact push the
log intentionally this is not an
accident this was not something that old
just happened but one of the boys
attorneys argues his client had no idea
the log would kill someone the
prosecution cannot prove murder which is
the most serious of the charges unless
they can prove that this log was pushed
over the edge knowing that it would kill
somebody and I I do not think they can
do that Ohio law states that someone can
be charged with murder in the second
degree if they do something
intentionally that leads to a death even
if the death itself is not premeditated
the judge believes
that they should be charged with murder
CBS News legal analyst Ricky Clemens
says as the case moves out of juvenile
court a grand jury will now determine
whether or not intentionally pushing
that log merits the murder charges I
think that the grand jury under these
circumstances will come back with one
charge or another and not simply let
them walk free Schafer's family remains
devastated we spoke to her sister Kathy
who told us Shafer died doing what she
loved she got the opportunity to you
know leave corporate America and pursue
her photography of all time she's drawn
and pained and do all these things but
photography ended up being her medium
that helped her do what she really loved
both teens are still in juvenile
detention centers on $100,000 bond The
Washington Post reports a grand jury
could decide whether or not to indict
them today and if that happens they
could appear before a judge next week
with a trial to follow it's chilling
stuff I mean as a parent if you have
boys in particular it seems like it's
always boys in these cases you've been
one dumb thing really dumb stuff and
this is the time to remind them it can
change lives forever hard to hear though
that it was bad enough to hear about the
Schafer's death but then there she was a
mother of four takes on that home that's
just read tragic all the way around yeah
tarika thank you